here they are striated Caracara is doing
what they do best managing this is
exactly the type of seeing a National
Geographic crew X spectra to catch on
camera when they went to the frigid
Falkland Islands what they didn't expect
well the birds are better known by
another name
Johnny rooks which is one of those
old-time phrases for thieves pillagers
and mischief-makers these birds are also
good at destroying things like well
campsites for instance
besides simple vandals stealing food is
a specialty and once the rumor gets out
then a free meal is available the Johnny
rooks have themselves beat this thievery
isn't for personal enrichment
this is havoc for the heck of it and for
that purpose it doesn't get any better
than messing with toilet paper so why
was the crew here in the first place to
capture Johnny whoops as they reveal
their very own generation gap actually
more like a chasm and an old Johnny rook
wayde's into a bunch of adolescents to
take control of our Rockhopper penguin
carcass and teach these young punks a
thing or two about who's in charge dear
this develops like he's gonna kick some
tail feathers and he does a thorough
convincing job
[Music]
after this trashy the adult discovers
the young Johnny Rose still don't appear
to realize who rules this woods his mate
plans to pray together they show they
mean business
this is a mean nasty take-no-prisoners
battle the adults win and celebrate with
a raucous victory
and then enjoy the spoils of victory the
young Johnny rooks get a one-way ticket
to Palookaville
this is a harsh desolate island and
finding food here is no easy task they
scour the coastline for anything edible
one thing is certain
a penguin dinner with the folks is not
in their future